this is not suffering
but this is absurd i just noticed
there's a box
with the big bow on it next to you
what's in the box michael it's your
present so it's your present for new
year's uh can we open it yeah sure
what's in the box
it's gonna take and you brought up
suffering this is gonna be very
unpleasant here you go
i packed it myself
yeah there's a whole process in there
so there's three presents in there
lex
i'll read the card first okay
something about opening presents
like tearing stuff
makes me feel like because like i just
tore this sheet of paper yeah so it'll
never be the same again
it's entropy it's entropy times you've
got a powerful voice
you've got a powerful voice
deluxe
thank you maybe i should read the other
card first
you've got a powerful voice listening to
what you have to say always puts me in a
hopeful place i feel like this is
building up to something you show me how
change can happen when you face the
world with pride confidence and a voice
that can't be silenced keep speaking up
the world is listening yeah
there's no cynicism in this card no this
is about this is new year's this is all
about helping joy
what to lex i'm seeing the binary uh
delex thank you for setting the path for
me to move to austin
zero one
zero zero one
zero one one zero one one zero zero zero
one one one zero one zero one
michael mouse yeah
brings tears to my eyes
thank you brother my pleasure
let's get to the present
okay
it's a it's a pc box
this is very promising
it better not be sex toys
there's nothing this is all there's
nothing inappropriate
at all why would it
why would sex toys be inappropriate
because you're sex positive because
you're a version
yeah bring a knife to a party
how clever is it to put in a pc box well
i had it i just got a new pc
okay
yeah open the cam first open the can
you wrap this yourself
[Laughter]
that scares [ __ ] out of me
i could get back in the can that
actually stayed in there that's magic
you just gotta cut the string
no
you're the most beautiful troll of all i
love you so much
this is awesome
did it not work
pick it up
oh it didn't work
there's a terrifying springy feeling to
this thing
i don't want to open this
i need to move stuff aside
i hate you so much what what
oh is it the other way no just pick it
up
thank you so much
wrenches they're my favorite
i can't believe i fell for that
okay
and there's box number three it's like a
matryoshka i can't believe that worked
yeah
i wanted the box to open all these gears
to fall out but you can't get you can't
get them yeah does that really
grind your
glass you know what graduation is
why am i scared
okay
this
there's another box
this leads to my death no no this is
this is there's a story behind it
i can't believe that worked
oh god that's so good all right
all right no springs no weapons no
wrenches
okay so let me tell you the story behind
that
toy
robots that turn into vehicles so when
you there when i was a kid
you had transformers
but for us poor people
you had gobots right
so the gobots there were four main
characters for the good guys it was
leader one small foot turbo and scooter
and what was annoying is when you had
the action figures
you couldn't find the ones that were on
the tv show
and i was a big gobots fan as a kid
and i went once to the toys r us
in caesars bay in brooklyn with my
grandfather my grandfather was always
very lucky like just good things
happened to him every so often
and i went there i remember very vividly
they must have just unpacked just loaded
the shelves and how they had the
shelving it would be like like a grid
you know you'd have like it was like one
two three four five
five rows and like uh five by five
and i remember it was like two up and
then you have to do you have to sit by
the side
and kind of sort through them and with
the gobots each package had a picture of
the different figures so the packaging
wasn't uniform and they just had scooter
there
she was just sitting there and i was
like holy crap so
that feeling
when you're a kid and you find that
just sitting on the shelf it is right
there it's just it was such this was
this that scooter no i have it though
but that one is for you i thought if you
want to put it next to your other robots
yeah open it up i can open it up yeah
yeah it's for you and that way uh
it's that symbol of joy when you have
when you're a kid when you find
something you really want
i think it just is really like so when
people look at it they'll be like
don't be hopeless i'll open this
carefully later no do it just yeah it
should do it yeah okay there's no way to
open it carefully
kids don't open stuff carefully you rip
that crap open but then you break it and
you cry that's what happens when you're
kid i never did that okay
me neither i never cried but never got
presents either
that is so cool all right scooter
you symbolize
childlike discovery right
the poor the poor man's robot
the poor man's transformers
i think there's instructions on the back
how to transform her
to her i only found out as an adult that
it was supposed to be a girl yeah
wow this changes everything
thank you
that's incredible
no give me here let me show it looks
better when she's
transformed what no there's there's
levels to that statement oh
how does it do like this let me see if i
remember how to do it
because i had this as a kid
arms out
what god
the thing is these are easy to break i
remember
is it like this
no oh the the front comes out oh let me
see this
oh this comes up yeah yeah yeah
yep so that's that
the arms go
i'm having visions of like baby michael
i i can't do it okay i can't do it i
can't figure it out wow you're right she
looks so much better transformed
oh
all right
i'm going to follow the instructions in
a bit and i'll leave yeah yeah yeah i'm
i'm i'll leave this failed project of
yours
oh there's a wheel out
look
i don't like this in between form
well
this is how it's gonna be okay
because we're gonna be accepting of the
transformation
that takes time okay
i got uh
i saw this
oh it's this little thing when i was
walking on congress and it says uh
resist it's a bracelet i mean i think of
you the reason i got it is because
there's two bracelets
so one said lucky [ __ ]
and the other one said resist now i
first saw resist and i'm like and then i
saw the lucky [ __ ] and i realized i'm a
lucky [ __ ] to find a irrelevant
it makes me think of you this is very
nice resist the powerful
that's true
you